let's talk in the prison company
thinking they do a better job and I
investigate it and I sold it
okay you know when you're brought that
they've done that this question and in
fact since then I've worked to end the
use of private prisons in my home state
and we've ended it
I've started a bank to support black
ownership of businesses women-owned
mentorship of businesses and Latino
owners are business owners of businesses
because this financial service industry
is prejudiced I have worked tirelessly
on this and you know I'm right you wrote
the crime bill we come from that's
called Charlie come lately there are
other beaver here but hundreds of
thousands of young black and Latino not
gin okay let me say something key
there's some not going on I have working
racial justice thank you lately and that
is a navigator
you
watching right now and you support my
campaign go to Pete for america.com
and chip in and if you're watching right
now and you're a billionaire I will
raise your taxes but if you'd like to
defeat Donald Trump please go to Pete
for america.com and donate the legal
maximum of two thousand eight hundred
dollars
you